so jack flaherty getting the call here
in game one
eight starts this year and he was
terrific last time out against
pittsburgh their issues at times
with their offense the same can be said
with milwaukee up the middle spinning
throwing
paul the young and he makes the play
in the 3-2 pitch by flaherty
swing and amaze he struck him out went
off speed in the first strikeout for
jack flaherty the issue now is an
oblique strength for him swing and a
miss and the tag applied by molina
here's brent suter now his fourth start
yeah fourth start the team is
two and one in his first three starts
that's off their typical timing
little squibber hit left side bobble
just a bit wrong will beat it out with
the speed of wong you have to field it
cleanly
and there's his first out first strike
out of the game for suitor as edmond
goes down
and this one to arcia double play in the
way and he got it done
so two aboard for milwaukee here in the
second inning that'll bring up jed jerko
the former saint louis cardinal
following two strikes
jericho puts it in place slow roller
and a nice play made by the third
baseman edmond to record the out runners
get to second and third with one out for
eric sogard to try and drive him in and
give the brewers the lead 1-1 pitch
sogart hits it into shallow center of
base hit one run's going to score
vogelback will be held at third and the
brewers take the lead
it's one nothing on an eric sogard
run scoring single how hot is eric
sogard right now
another roller to third they'll concede
the run and get the out at first base so
the brewers two to nothing now here in
the second
milwaukee as they try to
all fight for that number eight spot in
the wild card chase as suitor gets the
strikeout wearing a uniform his entire
career
and molina can't check his swing there
and another strikeout for brent suter
two in a row here in a second they call
him the little miggy
and a swing and a miss
o2 pitch to christian yelich
and flaherty falls down oh goodness
let's hope he's all right
boy ye just had such an awkward landing
and i don't know what happened whether
he just got a bad spot on the mound and
i thought maybe it would have to do with
an ankle or something we'll have to kind
of see that unfold here as chris conroy
is out checking with him and he just did
not land
solidly and
hope he's all right
that's good to see hops right back up
and he's all right three balls and two
strikes
yelich sends this one out to center beta
racing back he looks up and it is gone
christian yelich goes deep
and the brewers extend that lead to
three to nothing
christian yelich with his 12th home run
of the season and boy does it come at a
big time
and o'neill strikes out for out number
one here in the third fourth strikeout
for brent suiter
line drive into right and the catch is
made by dylan carlson
and that saves a run
and this 101 hopper to short could be
two
and it is
yeah good pitch by flaherty got up and
in on it
not this time bogoback strikes out
and he called strike three top of the
zone and jerko goes down for the first
out and the one two on the way
and sogar can't lay off there's the
second out
first battery faced was a strikeout
and it's been going pretty good ever
since
this could be two arcia the throw in
time
and one two three on those pitches
edmond goes down josh hader said to take
the mound the brewers preserving a
three-nothing lead here in st louis
first game of the double header so this
is closing time here in the seventh
inning so closed
and that's a
base hit out to left
gets past yelich and paul goldsman was
ready for that fastball
and picks up a leadoff double
here's the 3-2
this one grounded to third urias
there is an out there the brewers make
the playoffs he for sure will not pitch
in the first round at least and molina
goes down swinging he's out number two
there you go that high fast ball such an
effective pitch 3-2 on the way
and a strike three half-swing hater
takes care of business and the brewers
win it here three to nothing to take
game one